better looks pretty interesting so I
appreciate you coming over here this is
basically the stuff I want to start out
with the stuff that you should probably
take away from this I think it's
probably if you're not already familiar
with this stuff it'll probably be a
little bit too much to just in 30
minutes but these are the kind of main
takeaways I wanted to mention rudolph
Coleman he's guy who obviously invented
this algorithm back in the 1960s
very very famous and distinguished
scientist inventor who actually passed
away about two months ago it sounds like
something that you would use on Star
Trek but it's actually an algorithm it's
a recursive algorithm and it's very
strongly connected to this idea of
state-space models of time series one of
the key ideas that it combines sources
of information to give you a better
estimate than you could get with either
of them independently and a lot of
different time series models still can
here okay um is that any better
okay I think I might have been blocking
microphone and and the other thing is
just liquidus it's used in all sorts of
applications most of my examples will
focus on econometrics applications but
uh you know use think spaceship probably
there's probably some implementation tip
of it in the laptop that you're using
right now some preliminary notes when
I'm using a development version of stats
models I don't think the release version
has any of the state space stuff in it
yet
I I just build from source but I think
this is version eight release candidate
I should just use this one
is it help better if I hold it like this
so if you look at the development
version of the stats model source you'll
actually see there's two versions of
common filters one is an older version
which i think is in the actual current
release version which is used for
parameter estimation on what are called
auto regressive models also I'm using
the terminology for common filters
that's from a book by Durbin and Koopman
called the time series analysis by
States based methods there's a lot of
information on these out there and it's
used in a lot of different domains and
so you'll see different different
variables using equations different
terminologies different ways of
explaining how this thing works this is
kind of econometrics you of the world so
this we're going to start the basic
listen I'm going to start is just a very
simple time series which is a random
walk so you know it looks
often probably reproduce it on next ones
so say that we have a secondary time
second time series which is just that
first time series plus some noise so the
original time series is the blue - is
the series with the noise is the green
line so basically what you're asking
with the column and filter in a very
simple sense is if we don't have that
original blue time series what can we
infer about it from just this noisy
green time series so this example is
actually a very simple version of what's
called a state space model this is
called the local level model but
basically all states based models have
this idea of there being a state
equation and an observation equation or
sometimes called a measurement equation
that first equation that described the
random walk is our state equation and
the second equation which describes the
bat series plus plus the noise is the
observation equation so it's called the
observation equation because why the Y
values are the things that we expect to
be able to observe but we're trying to
get back to information about the Alpha
alphas the actual States so these are
just some quick examples of what that
might mean you know obviously the sort
of generic idea of having a signal a
signal plus noise that's that's actually
where this idea of it being called a
filter comes from is you know you can
think of this in terms of signal
processing you have a noisy SiC other
noise a signal that you can measure and
what you really want to do is filter out
the noise and get the original signal
the state may be the position or
position and velocity of a vehicle you
know a spaceship or a robot and what you
can actually measure is measurement from
a sensor that's a you know a satellite
or GPS or something like that
another example I've seen is you want to
you want to anticipate with what a
commodity price is going to be but those
don't change quickly enough because you
only get information on those when
people bid on that commodity but people
bid on futures more frequently so if you
have futures prices you might be able to
infer commodity price from futures
prices and you know my trackpad example
if there may be a common filter and
certain and certain
computing devices just to keep track of
where your where your cursor should be
based on where you're moving your finger
so this is what a linear state-space
model looks like in general I'll cover
this in more later but basically all
we've added here are some some equations
some terms that you know make us make
this more generic so in the state
equation we now have these terms T which
is sometimes called the transition
matrix which sort of describes the
dynamics from one step to the next step
and this matrix Z and the observation
equation is sometimes called the design
equation it sort of relates how the
state values are connected to the
observation values so I'm going to jump
into the way stats models does this and
in particular this is the more the
development version that Chad Fulton
developed so this is hopelessly
old-school much like myself so the this
is a basically a UML class diagram on
the right-hand side is basically the
series of classes in in in stats models
that define the time series machinery at
least as it's used in in the state space
stuff and on the left-hand side is
another class hierarchy which describes
the state space model and the way
they're connected is through this this
model called MLE model or maximum
likelihood estimation model and
basically what that allows you to do is
use the common smoother as a way to
determine the parameters given a time
series so if you have a time series as
input and you need to you know
estimate means and variances and that
time set the semele model will let you
do that using the machinery of stats
model so I'm going to do now is this is
not something you should probably do in
general but what I'm going to do now is
I'm going to create a common filter
class that specify that first initial
simple model that we use just by
manually plugging in the various various
matrices in the in the state space model
in that K in this case they're literally
trivial because they're either matrices
of ones or constant ones but this is
this is enough to define a state space
model given that the Kalman filter class
and the next what I'm going to do is
once I've defined it I'm going to
simulate it so again you'll see a
simulation here which is fairly similar
to the the set of time series I showed
the first couple of slides so this this
visualization is trying to try to
explain some of the terminology of the
common filter at state space stuff so
when you're when you get the new
observation and you're trying to
determine the best estimate for the next
state that process is called filtering
and what I was trying to denote that
with a vertical line here so if you are
trying to predict points into the future
that's forecasting or prediction
there's also another process called
smoothing smoothing goes backwards in
time but basically what you need to do
to smooth the states is you need to run
the common filter forward up until up
until all of the you've gotten all of
the points in the time series and then
you run a process backwards to basically
interpolate new States or smoothen
excuse me the green triangles here are
examples of what you call the filtered
state so typically what will happen is
that as you get new observations you
you estimate a state the filter today
which you hope is closer to the actual
state than the observation that you get
the vertical line between the last
observed point on the red line and the
state 80 sometimes called the forecast
error it's also called innovation so
that's that's basically the difference
between what your next best prediction
is if you don't know you don't know the
next observation and the best prediction
if you do not so I won't expect you to
to digest this right away but this is
one recursion for this particular simple
model basically each line corresponds to
one step in the process so the first
step we determine the what's called the
innovation the forecast error from the
new observation calculates variance and
then we calculate the filtered state and
forecast States so what we're really
trying to determine is a new conditional
distribution so a distribution of the
state given the observations that we
have what we start out off with is some
estimate of the state at that prior to
that observation and what we sort of
know is we sort of know the distribution
of the possible next States and we sort
of know the distribution of possible
errors in that next state and so with
this history with these histograms are
trying to show is if I if I know the
state if I know the current state I can
sort of predict that the next state just
based on the distribution I know at that
time which is the sort of blue histogram
the green histogram is the distribution
of possible forecast errors for the next
state so what we know when get the next
observation which we're calling YT now
we can actually calculate the actual
value for that forecast
there VT and we also in a sense know the
relationship between the next state and
that forecast error and if this this
slide seems out of place like it made
your head spin a little bit I apologize
for that but roll with me here for a
second so there's many ways to explain
this idea this is the one that Durbin
and Koopman let use and I I like it
seems to make sense to me
this is a this is a simple lemma the
mathematical lemon that has to do with
basically linear regression so this
applies to least scores regression so
you've got these two variables a and B
which are jointly distributed bivariate
normal distribution and this lemma says
that the distribution of a given B and
the variance of a given B correspond to
these two equations on the bottom so
this is important for a couple of
reasons
so we can we can use our state our next
state alpha t and the innovation B T as
a and B I'm going to focus on the
covariance between the two things so if
you work through this it turns out the
covariance is this value PT which is
actually the covariance of the state of
current at the current time period and
you'll see that this particular ratio PT
over PT plus Sigma epsilon squared comes
up twice in these equations and that
ratio is called the Coleman gain and I
put a box around it because it's kind of
the key idea in the common filter and so
intuitively what this means is that if
the error that noise in the observation
is small then this ratio is going to be
close to 1 and so that means that the
value that you observe is probably
pretty close to the actual state and so
you want to you want to
move your estimate to that closer to
that actual observation if the noise in
the measurement is large on the other
hand then this this ratio will get
progressively smaller and that means
that you're probably better off staying
closer to the state that you estimated
without the observation it's also worth
noting that using that lemma on the
previous page and and what's shown here
it this is actually the optimal estimate
given linear system and Gaussian
distributions much like least squares
regression so on that slide earlier we
talked about filtering and basically
filtering is again the idea of trying to
find a better estimate for the current
state given the latest observation what
you're really trying to find is this
conditional distribution so if we just
use our column and filter model that we
used before what I'm going to do is I'm
going to cheat and initialize the
initial known state to something that I
already know and then I'm going to bind
that Y the observations to the common
filter and then I'm going to run the
filter forward and what you end up with
is something like this is that like no
frequency so why is the why is the set
of observations and the red dashed lines
or the actual States which you know in
normal cases we don't know and the blue
dots are the the filtered state so with
forecasting it's very similar process
except what we're looking for is the
next value in the time series and the
trick of it here is that we don't have
an observation for this we're just
trying to estimate the next point in the
time series given what we what we know
about previous observations and the
state
again it's it's we're really calculating
a conditional distribution so this is
the this is a forecast out for I think
ten time periods given our so-called
local level model and you'll notice that
it's basically a flat line that runs
from the the last estimated state and
that that's pretty typical of the of
this particular model so once you once
you have no longer once you no longer
have observations the forecast being
carried forward are basically the the
mean of of the very last state that you
you were able to determine through
filtering and again this is like the
simplest case of it of forecasting just
to back up a little bit there's a lot of
things we ignored in this discussion so
far so one of them is that I assumed
that I already knew these parameters
these variances of the time series that
I'm starting with which is generally not
the case normally you need to take the
data that you have and estimate these
parameters from the data that's
essentially what the common smoother
does that but that's why when you're
using the models in the in the stats
model state space package typically you
want something that's derived from this
mlu model class because that class will
do this process for use in the normal
stats model time series and shading we
also typically don't really know what
the first state is and so there needs to
be some way to initialize that first
state and the a fairly common method and
one that seems to work pretty well a lot
of cases is what's called a diffuse
prior which is kind of a fancy term for
guessing so basically you say the mean
is 0 and the variance is ridiculously
large and we'll start from there so when
you move on to more complicated
state-space models the recursion for the
Kalman filter gets a little more
complicated and again I realize this is
not super easy to read but
the same idea holds here you've got one
set of equations at the top that you've
got three lines of equations one of
which is calculating the next mean value
and this on the right hand side one of
which is calculating the variance of the
distribution mainly what's happening
here is you're introducing the T matrix
the transition matrix to make the
dynamics a little more interesting and
the Z matrix to to make the relationship
between the state and the observation
more interesting so the next the next
example I'm going to show is within
stats models called an unobserved
components model if you work with the
time series models you might also call
this a structural time series model so
it's it's a type of model where the time
series is divided up into a bunch of
components so you know a trend and some
you know some random mean and a trend
and and you know possibly a seasonal
seasonal aspect and so forth I'm going
to do a really really simple structural
model which just has a random trend so
this is a data time starting with here
is industrial production data from from
Fred Federal Reserve and I'm gonna this
is what this model this local is called
a local level model or local linear
trend model this is what it looks like
in state space form
so those three there's three equations
top describe the model and then the ones
at the bottom describe its form and
state space one and this is basically
how you set it up in stats model
basically I'm saying I have a level and
I have a trend in both of them are
stochastic or random and then I fit that
data set to get the parameters that I
need I'm not showing the summary of the
model because it fills up way too much
space on the slide
I'm not sure if you can actually see it
here but when you when you do forecast
with the with this local linear trend
model what you basically end up with is
a line with more or less constant slope
it's kind of hard to see the slope here
but there is a vector slope and it will
again it will the column and filter at
this stage since our our T matrix and Z
matrix note vary with time we'll have
reached a steady state and so every
forecast after the after we have
observations is just going to give us
this constant trend the gray part is the
uncertainty confidence interval in the
forecast and so I think the basic idea
it's trying to convey is that at the
further you get away from having an
actual observation the more uncertainty
you have I think that's fairly intuitive
to understand but you know it's it's
really well spelled out in the math of
Kalman filter another thing another
reason why states based models are are
popular with the economists in
particular is that a lot of time series
models can be put into state space form
putting the whole zoo what are called
ARIMA models this is a just a simple
example of what's called an auto
regressive model and this is this is the
top equation is the normal auto
regressive time series model and the
stuff at the bottom is the state space
form of it and these are the design
transition and the r matrix is what's
called the selection matrix and
basically that maps so the shocks that
we have the the random parts in the
series now come from a multivariate
distribution and this selection matrix
basically says I want to take since it's
a it's only one 0 here that says I just
need one random component so it's
basically if you look at the previous
slide
we just have an epsilon there so the R
matrix is basically selecting one
element from this bivariate distribution
to add it as an error term so I I'm
trying to build a model here using
what's called a Serra max model which
again is one of the implementations in
the stats model state space library and
but what I'm trying to accomplish here
is to forecast electricity demand in the
industrial sector having read some some
papers on this the the common idea is
that demand is affected by industrial
production and the price of competing
energy sources so this is what
industrial electricity demand looks like
and probably the first thing you notice
is that there's a fairly prominent
seasonal aspect to it so the first thing
you want to do in this type of model is
figure out you know what that
seasonality is and this is monthly data
so typically that means a 12-month
season this is the stats model seasonal
decompose function which does a lot of
the work for you to to show you the
seasonal parts in the trend in your your
data so that the top series there is the
original data and the the line in the in
the second row down is the trend in the
data third row third row down is the
seasonal component and the hot part at
the bottom is the residuals the
residuals and ideally would look like
white noise here they look like they
probably have a little bit of structure
to them still
so I don't want to go into this too
deeply but if you're doing these types
of ARIMA models basically the thing you
have to do is you have to figure out
where the auto correlations are in your
data and typically the way you do that
is you difference the time series to
find the seasonal aspect you difference
the time series to find any other auto
correlations and then you can plot these
auto correlations and partial Auto
correlation diagrams don't know if the
the top these are these are actually
features and stats model - these plot
ACF and plot key ACF functions will plot
these auto correlations for you and so
roughly what this shows me is that there
are there are significant components at
both the 12-month lag in the partial
auto correlation and the correlation and
possibly a significant lag at one month
it turns out it works up better if I
include the auto correlation in that but
not the moving average part
excuse me and again I think it got cut
off but this is in stats model how you
set up this type of Serra max model this
particular example all I'm using is the
original time series there's no so
called exogenously at a-- so there's no
regression variables in here so this is
this is what a forecast looks like of
this time series using state space model
in the column filter you can see that it
does pick up the seasonal part in the
auto and the auto regressive part in the
time series and the great part is the
confidence interval of that of that
forecast this next model is basically
the same thing except in this case I am
including the the extra so called
exogenously Abele's the industrial
production very
was that the energy price variables
and again the difference on this
particular one is that to do to do this
forecast into the future you also need
future values of the exogenous variables
and in fact that's probably why you
would do it model like this because
those variables may be easy to access
access the band than the variable that
you're trying to forecast but in this
case what I've done is cheat and leave
out the last two years and treat those
as data that I'm predicting so what this
shows is that again the Green Line is
the forecast and the gray area is the
uncertainty in the forecast and the
black dots are what the original series
has so enough time yeah I just want to
go over a couple of extensions to the
Kalman filter real quick one one common
thing is there's something called the
extended Kalman filter so one thing that
I probably didn't make clear in the
earlier slides is that this is
essentially a linear linear dynamic so
you're multiplying a previous time step
by a matrix and so it's a linear
relationship a lot of times that doesn't
work and so people have created what's
called the extended Kalman filter which
allows you to have nonlinear dynamics in
the Kalman filter there's a variation
called the unscented Kalman filter and
then recently there's been a lot of
interest in what are called particle
filters which they're much more
computationally intensive and more
difficult to explain but they take a lot
of the assumptions out of the out of the
process there's no assumption about the
distribution of the data there's no
assumption about the about stuff being
linear and that's about it
you know I recommend Durbin and Koopmans
book if you if you want to learn about
this Koopman also wrote a another book
on state space analysis which is a
little bit simpler and there's this blog
post called how common filters work on
the uncommon lab website which if you
can only read one thing about these I
highly recommend it it's very very
complicated and and lengthy post but it
covers everything from particle filters
to the basic common filter and if you
can work through it it's it's a really
really good piece of work that's it for
me no idea covariance estimation for of
a ensemble common filter
um yeah I think I mean I think there's
an assumption that if you have I think
part of the reason is that this is not a
particularly good model the the it turns
out that some of these energy variables
which are supposed to be good predictors
of electricity demand don't seem to be
for instance coal price does not really
seem to be a that good of an indicator
of industrial electricity but I left it
in just to just to see what would happen
so I think I think probably just the
issue of not having a very good model is
is more to blame here than not having
more observations
oh yeah yeah definitely
you
sort of I mean I'm not entirely sure
that's that's that's true I mean the
common filter should to some extent
update as you go I mean one one issue
that I did not have time to explore here
just for time constraints is the the
dynamics in the state equation can be
time time dependent so and most of these
models it'll it'll reach a steady state
at some point and then everything after
that it doesn't really update the Kalman
filter anymore
but you can't have situations where you
can make those vary by time so
continuously it will update them as you
go
I personally have not had situations
like that although but it is it is
actually one of the key features of the
common filter is that it deals really
well with missing observations in fact
forecasting in the common filter is
effectively the exact same thing as as
predicting the state without an
observation and so you know for instance
in the in the one of the variables that
you can use for this electricity model
is gasoline prices and for reasons I
don't understand when you load that when
you download that from the federal
government sometimes they just leave out
months but it's it's relatively easy
it's much easier with a common filter
and state-space models to do that to
handle that kind of data that is with
with normal estimation methods known
time series methods
probably our that that's that's the most
probably developed area for common
filters I believe that that uncommon lab
blog post I believe they do most of
their work in MATLAB as well and I don't
know it I don't know of any particle
filter implementations in Python yet so
but they are an are not I'm sorry yeah I
I put them on my I put them on my about
an hour ago
so catches that this is a so this is an
actual PI ipython notebook so when you
look at it on github or if you download
it it won't look like the slides unless
you install rise but yeah there's
there's a link on my Twitter handles
quick step k wik step there's a link to
it there
I just run a common filter per se
well you can even and it's all the base
implementation is in Saipan and see so
you know if you have a lot of data it's
it's still pretty fast
well I guess I think of them as being in
slightly different realms but I mean you
could conceivably use capable
cross-validation to do a out-of-sample
validation of a common filter I think
it's kind of hard to do Kate it's kinda
hard to do cross validation on time
series it's sort of a black art but yeah
I get I guess the place where you would
choose to use Kalman filters as opposed
to more traditional time series
techniques I think are one you have
non-stationary data so if you if you
don't know what non-stationary means
then probably don't care and the other
one is you have missing observations and
those are really both those are two
cases where the Kalman filter really is
superior to normal time series models
you